uh
you never ratted no see a lot of people
there's like uh i feel like i got mixed
emotions about that
i feel like because he what this guy
said john alex i know what he's gonna
say
he said like there's no loyalty
everybody rats on everybody it's not
true
it's not true but but he is right a lot
of them are ratting
oh a ton of them are rating uh but that
doesn't make you why should you
does it your word listen i told you
today he said basically if
if 20 guys went out went on the [ __ ]
stand and ratted him out and put him
away
why the [ __ ] wouldn't he i know what he
said i know but that's
that's just a way to justify what you
did let me ask you a question
i told you today i'd be here at 11
o'clock
yeah was i here you were here because my
word means something
right i went away for four 12-year
sentences
and i was offered three years and i had
a 15 month old kid
a six-year-old son and a lot of money
god
i lost it all you know why because my
word
meant something to this day
i used to look into that so the the the
uh
[ __ ] stainless steel that's what it
is in prison you don't have glass
stainless steel mirror and no with
nothing
remind you they took every dime from me
everything from me
but my word was good to this day
i'm gonna die with my word being good
when i told you i would be here
i would be here now obviously if the rv
broke or something i have a phone i
would call you
that's why i even asked my son i said
make sure you get his number
right i don't i i i think a what
person's words should mean something now
absolutely
i understand why they do it that that
don't get into business
right now and i understand listen i
don't consider listen
first of all civilians can't rap
that's another thing i tell you or if
you're a civilian
you see a crime you should go pick them
out of a lineup you should do everything
the [ __ ] you're supposed to
it's not ratting ratting is you and ryan
[ __ ] selling coke
you getting caught and saying it was
[ __ ] ryan to get out of the problem
mm-hmm that's ratty okay i don't believe
in that
right i don't i did crimes nobody went
to prison on my case
nobody really no offense
nobody so he he can't say everybody's
riding
right are a lot ratting absolutely
they're backstabbing each other sammy
gravano did it he knows he
probably told you all this i don't know
what you got out of it learned
we didn't talk much about sammy garvano
he he was with john gotti jr
right john elite and he worked for the
book
john gotti himself right and they were
all murderers they did their [ __ ] and
everything else they cut this [ __ ] hit
the fan
and one rats after the other and and
oh he ratted on me he was gonna rat on
me i i know he was gonna rat so i ratted
first
listen how why you did what you did and
why you even got in that business
yeah listen i sleep really really good
yeah it's not because i was the rough
guy
it's not because of that i feel i i
sleep good at night because my word
meant something i'm okay with everything
yeah i caused a lot of damage i did i
didn't uh i guess i'd never heard
anybody that was in my business or any
you know that kind of
never hurt somebody just to hurt them or
anything of that nature
uh so you want to call that a
justification it's still not because
there were people in the jewelry stores
that were scared for their life and all
that and i
i feel for that i really do i mean it
can't change it it's not like oh okay
you know you can never change that
but i feel good let's cause i know if i
tell somebody
and and they call that facing the devil
i faced the devil and stood up to him
meaning the courts in the dead you know
right i faced him
and stood up to him now
i could have [ __ ] ratted everybody
out my fences
everybody out and got three years
probably less
and been home kept money whatever but
you know what i have a great
relationship with my son
you know and my daughter i'm not married
or anything like that
but and i got a really good relationship
and we're all wild that's gotta be like
it's the hardest decision for a lot of
people
it's gotta be such a hard [ __ ]
decision but it shouldn't be if you know
what family could buy
or keep my dignity or just tell on the
scumbag
and get my life back yeah but see you're
making it a scumbag now yeah i'm
saying but there's different ways of
looking at that but what happens if it's
some who's close to you right i don't
know who's close to you but whoever's
close to you
are you going to put them away right so
what
at what point it has nothing no i see i
see there's nothing to do with them i
see what you're saying
dan it has everything to do with you
nobody took care of me when i was in
there the mob don't take care of that
he's right that's all [ __ ]
right right but it meant me
when i looked in that [ __ ] stainless
steel i did it for me
right i didn't rap because of me now i
i used to hate them you know oh [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] what they do
yeah they gotta live with themselves
right they could justify it all they
want they could lay in bed and justify
the murders they committed
i had a guy on here tell me a story
about how when he was in he was in
federal prison he was in there for like
15 years
he told me a story about how he was
walking the yard with some guy who
basically
got life and he was confessing all of
his
[ __ ] where he hid money he took the
information and went and gave it to the
feds
and got out knocked up got time yeah
he's like
i would cut anyone's throat i could find
it's like anyone gave me something i
would cut their throat instantly
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they call that
jumping on the bus and they call it yeah
it's called a rule 35. mary told your
lawyer yeah
you get a rule 35 post conviction
you know yeah and it was just never my
thing and i
understa that's first of all i used to
teach you don't shut your [ __ ] mouth
because you don't know who you're
dealing with right but
yeah i mean that's just being stupid
right but i
i think i think that all goes to the
person that like like i said i could
leave here
have a car accident and you're going to
say you know larry was a good guy
whatever i hope oh sure and uh i
i know the people around me know that
and i have very good friends
that that know hey larry if larry tells
you you're gonna be there he's gonna
[ __ ] be there
because his word means something yeah
how much is it would you
ever get into business with a dude who
ratted [ __ ] no how do you trust him if
anything trust is everything
trust is everything if anything goes
wrong oh he was gonna [ __ ] steal the
money anyway
he's you know he's the one who did the
tax [ __ ] thing he
how do you trust somebody now
listen again i used to hate them but i
don't give a [ __ ] about him anymore i
just
do your things yeah someone asked me are
you going to interview sammy gravano
right asked you to do it yeah yeah yeah
yeah cause you know i got a million he's
got 150 000
but he's he's up and coming he was a big
mob you heard who he is
sure i said no
and and you know michael francis
um who's that you should get him on your
show he's got 300 good good show
really and he's legit he didn't rat he
he took a plea
like we all did but nobody went to jail
in his case
that's all i could say okay and you got
into he's a great guy
okay good guy anyway so
and mike and i talked about that because
we're both in the mob right you know
we're both with the mob and we same here
i was 10 years after them he was born in
uh 51 i was born 61.
okay but i knew of him he he was the
richest mobs ever he robbed 200 million
a month
a month 50 million a week had the
biggest gas scam in the world
what kind of scam they were stealing gas
taxes
what good look it up just put gas
schedules holy [ __ ]
put microphone gas scam just mob gas
scam
okay uh michael francis mobs gas
whatever you wanna do
anyway uh so and we talked
about that he even saw you i said you
know michael it's it
i know every excuse they make for why
they ran yeah everybody makes it
he was gonna tell me first oh he was
gonna kill me whatever
oh they were scumbags anyway everybody
was doing it
and that's their way of justifying
whatever they did and however they and
they do that to live
because they never took they took the
oath to
never [ __ ] oh murta could never do
that
so they took this great oath lived by it
killed for it
yeah but then when it came down to they
couldn't face it that's what i looked
they couldn't face that demo
right now i could have did that i just
didn't and
and again it has nothing to do with them
it's something to do with me the way i
was raised
by my dad you know don't tattletail
you know when you were a kid don't
tattletail
you know that it was just the way i was
and and i do believe
everybody has to make that decision for
themselves
now i'll do research everybody i work
with
and anybody that [ __ ] did that i just
don't
work with him right i'm not gonna kill
them i don't give a [ __ ] what they do
go go live your own life i live a good
life right very happy a very happy life
like i said
pornhub yeah well whatever i want to do
i just i just think it's everybody has
to
that face their own things and and what
happens to me
i think dan is people are making
justifications for everything they want
and i i don't know your word i believe a
person's word is
all we have all we have money comes and
goes
i'm telling you whether you struggle now
or you don't yeah money comes and goes
i know a millionaire broke man it broke
comes and goes and i mean broke where
you [ __ ] ever can't [ __ ] afford
anything
i mean credit cards everything's done
right then you make it you think good
everything's good then it goes comes and
goes
but my word is never went people who
know me will do business with me because
my word
people who understand me know that he's
gonna tell you the [ __ ] truth he
don't give a [ __ ]
you know i'm very honest about that you
know who i am or whatever i am i mean
i'm
you know because i'm a public figure if
you want to call it the foundation of
who you are it's
extremely important man yeah and when
you lose that then what are you laying
your hat on
right exactly what are you what are you
going to say then oh yeah
yeah like you said i ratted but
he was gonna rat on me everybody and
he's right about all that
i'm not saying he's not right i know who
he is very much so
yeah i just he did what he did i
wouldn't
deal with him i wouldn't do business
with him and make it you know
for what right you know why because
something goes wrong hey nobody got your
back
so why do you want to live like that
yeah
do you want i don't want to live like
that yeah i mean you're going to suffer
to an extent depending on where your
moral compass is
you have to live with yourself at the
end of the day you gotta look in the
mirror you gotta
tuck yourself in at night and yeah yeah
and you gotta
also like you gotta like uh every
decision you make then
is gonna be is it right what's he gonna
do how's he gonna do it
you know oh man we shouldn't do it it's
almost the same thing as a lie right if
you're a liar you're always having to
navigate your way through other lies and
not get caught
you know people ask me all the time
about my uh going on shows and you can
go back and look
him shows for 10 12 years do i prepare
or what the [ __ ] no i don't lie right
ask me what i think did i ask you to you
can ask me anything the [ __ ] do you want
anything because it doesn't matter to me
because i'm not gonna sit here and lie
to you and have to worry about a lie
right or lied right you [ __ ] look at
me mob a zillion times i don't give a
[ __ ]
that well that's what makes my life
easier right of course you know
and people who can't he's right oh did i
tell him that guy
or did we kill that guy and i know the
fed's this or not you know
that's that's not the way i want to live
right and and people
again i i i respect you guys for
your age and coming up and getting
experience and doing it right
if there's any advice i give anybody is
this just be
listen you don't have to be true to the
public and you'll know what i mean as a
public figure because you are you know
obviously as an influencer but be
be true to you does that make sense
i don't give a [ __ ] what the public
knows about you but when you look in the
mirror
right be you right to yourself yep
obviously you don't have to [ __ ] tell
you everything because the headaches of
it and society
and business or whatever that's one way
but as long as you know who you are
oh yeah and then you're gonna live a
great life